what I want to talk to you about is the
Dark Horse duo plan which is now the
unity 2020 plan in order to give it a
little breathing room from the podcast
and other things here's the situation we
are getting a ton of positive feedback
on this plan people are really
enthusiastic about it it has captured
their imaginations but in order to make
it viable what we need are lots and lots
of people to sign up to follow our
Twitter account to look at our
whitepaper and to give us their email
address so that we can demonstrate that
this is an effort with enough momentum
that it can actually carry the day so
what I'm going to say is that this
podcast is going to reach something like
a hundred thousand people on YouTube
alone in the next couple of days if it
follows the pattern of recent live
streams if all of those people were
simply to follow our Twitter account go
to our whitepaper and give us their
email address it would greatly magnify
our credibility with those that we need
to reach in order to move forward so if
you have been following me some of you
have been following me for something
like three years now have you ever known
me to beg it's not my thing have you
ever known me today don't answer that
but what I'm going to do is I'm going to
beg you to go to those places it's
absolutely free just sign up follow us
and that will bring us to the next step
do you want to put this up yes I'd love
to put that up Zachary you can put up my
screen here so this is the Articles of
unity that that you posted and at the
bottom of it's this is on medium you can
find it by searching on unity twenty
twenty on medium and at the bottom of it
right or or is it on the separate
website it's down there at the bottom
okay that's so much Kat bell today
inquiry enquiries too for those who are
listening and not watching info at
articles of unity calm there's also if
you scroll up a little bit at a place to
just enter your email address and then
we can find you and if you have an offer
of help you can let us know what
capabilities you bring to the tape
I should also say there has been a great
deal of assistance help guidance
provided by members of the amazing yang
gang who are very enthused enthusiastic
about this plan we are of course very
interested in whether Andrew might
himself be willing to participate on the
ticket we would love to have him it's
not necessary that he be there and many
of the people in the yang gang are of
course they would prefer it to be him
but they don't need it to be him so for
those of you holdouts please join us
[Music]